so we are starting to see a bit of a
shift already
among uh individuals who have been
critical of donald trump
starting to go in the direction of if
trump runs i wouldn't run and if trump
runs i would support him the latest is
nikki haley nikki haley former
republican governor of south carolina
she was donald trump's ambassador to the
united nations for a relatively brief
period of time nikki haley is now
saying if trump runs she would not run
and if trump runs she would support
donald trump
just recently she was critical of trump
saying that trump would be judged
harshly
by history it seemed as though nikki
haley
maybe was starting to be more direct and
forthright
about her reservations about donald
trump and at the time when we reported
that i said to you
i think this is merely posturing i think
this is nikki haley
putting out some sort of very very light
possible critique whether we can even
call it a critique as a question mark
um and she's trying to play both sides
and
none of these people spoke out when
trump was still in power
none of them spoke out when they were
still working for donald trump and it
seems that that's exactly what it is
we're gonna look at a clip here
here is uh nikki haley saying uh yeah
if donald trump if donald trump runs she
would support it and she would not run
take a look at this
he still has a lot of popularity if he
runs again in 2024 will you support him
yes
if he decides that he's going to run
would that preclude any sort of run that
you would possibly make yourself
i would not run as president trump
and i would talk to him about it you
know that's something that we'll have a
conversation about at some point if
that decision is something that has to
be made but yeah i would absolutely i
had a great working relationship with
him i appreciated the way he let me do
my job
um i thought we did some fantastically
great foreign policy
things together and look i just want to
keep building on what we accomplished
and not watching
one of them when was the last time you
talked to him
after the election before january 6th
or after before january
so there it is i think that these this
is
first of all this is significant because
there's lots of people talking about
nikki haley running in 2024 herself
there are many republicans who are it's
nikki haley is not the traditional
republican wing
but she's also also not full q q anon
she's kind of in the middle
and there are there's a contingent of
the republican party that likes the idea
of nikki haley running for the
republican nomination
and uh when she so clearly says if trump
runs i won't even try to challenge him
and if trump runs i will i will support
him
that signals to us something about how
the 2024 republican primary would go
if it were held today and that is
exactly the way i've been talking about
it which is
based on republican support for trump
right now
it's trump's if he wants it if trump
fails to play king maker in the 2022
midterms if trump
supports marjorie taylor greene and
lauren bobo bobert
and madison cawthorne and they lose
that steals political capital from
donald trump
and if that happens his fundraising
beyond 2022 will
likely be hurt and if that happens it's
not seeming
super likely that donald trump will run
in 2024 but if it were held today
with something like 80 of republican
voters wanting trump involved
uh 60 of republican voters believing
trump won
the november 2020 election it is trump's
for the taking
at this point in time let me know what
other than the success or failure of
trumpian
members of congress and the senate could
determine
what trump does in 2024 i think trump's
health is always a question mark i mean
he's
obese he's not a healthy guy uh i think
that
that that four years from now three and
a half years from now that could be a
factor
uh but let me know what else you think
other than just this popularity we'll
take a quick break
after the break we will have the latest
very strange comments from senator john
kennedy
no relation to the democratic kennedy
family
i also have a voicemail for you some
people are very concerned about
me actually i'll tell you why we'll hear
the latest from mike lindell
and much much more stay with us